voilà un bon vélo qui devait partir à
tokyo comment elle a fini
donc la direction a été arrachée sur le
courant là il en carbone
cécile sabouraud et para triathlète elle
aurait dû être aux jeux paralympiques
cette année mais elle a subi un accident
lors de sa préparation près de vichy le
30 juillet dernier on faisait une boucle
de 10 km aller retour et on faisait des
blocs par exemple 5 km ou vraiment
fallait qu'on soit font une 1030
récupéreront répéter ça plusieurs fois
et donc sur mon dernier blogue de cinq
kilomètres à fond donc c'était le
quatrième juste à la fin j'étais sur une
route à caractère prioritaire et j'ai un
camion benne les gros camions bennes
poids lourds celui qui est venu couper
la route et je suis venu s'encastrer la
tête dans la benne la tête la première
un choc violent qui lui brise plusieurs
vertèbres elle doit porter un corset
pendant quatre mois le chauffard lui
prend la fuite une enquête est en cours
avec la brigade de vichy
pour se soigner cécile sabouraud va
opter pour une opération à la clinique
des franciscaines à versailles un
hôpital spécialisé dans le rachis c'est
là que nous la retrouvons dix jours
après son opération
un spin jacques avec 6 manteau plastique
en fait de spin jack on va s'introduire
de chaque côté de la verte elle par deux
trous des deux côtés et on va mettre un
espèce on va schématiser ça comme ça de
criques comme un crime de voitures qui
va réhausser la vertèbre et après on va
amener de me remettre le ciment qui va
prendre à peu près 45 minutes en prise
au total voilà pour revenir combler
remettre complètement la vertèbre à la
hauteur où elles étaient auparavant
rentré à l'hôpital le matin elle ressort
le soir même sans corset la mobilité je
la retrouve beaucoup plus rapidement que
si j'avais le corset pendant trois
quatre mois et en plus je suis beaucoup
plus sereine dans la tête de savoir
qu'effectivement la vertèbre on lui a
redonné son volume on lui a redonné de
la hauteur et qu'elle est consolidée
parce que voilà elle était passée de
plus de moitié et elle était ouverte en
deux
voilà et la consolidation n'était pas
certaine même avec un corset donc oui
c'est l'opération qui pour moi me
rassure et qui me paraît l'idéal dans
quelques jours cécile sabouraud va
pouvoir reprendre le sport doucement en
attendant elle regardera ses coéquipiers
de l'équipe de france à la télé j'ai
quand même un passement de pas être
là-bas pas être là là bas avec eux de
partager ça tout ce qu'on a mis en place
tout ce que j'ai mis en place aussi de
représenter mon pays et ne pas avoir la
chance de pouvoir me battre est de
ramener une médaille ça je suis vraiment
déçu mais je me dis que je suis debout
et que j'aurai ma revanche voilà
rendez-vous pris pour la revanche on
l'espère à paris en 2024